well
this is just kind of the place that our
relationship is at after 25 years
together sister wives christine and cody
announce they're splitting up mary i
can't do marriage with cody anymore i
don't want him you don't get to give up
like that i don't want to do it anymore
christine announced the news on social
media saying quote cody and i have grown
apart and have made the difficult
decision to leave we will continue to be
a strong presence in each other's lives
as we parent our beautiful children and
support our wonderful family at this
time we ask for your grace and kindness
as we navigate through this stage within
our family one two three four wives said
no we're never moving back to utah maybe
the drama problem in our lives is me
cody who considers himself to be
spiritually married to his four wives is
only legally married to robin he also
shared a statement on social media
saying quote christine's decision to
leave comes with a great deal of sadness
we enjoyed many years together and i
have a large amount of respect and
admiration for her
although we are moving forward on
different paths we will always remain
committed parents
more than anything i think that what we
do impacts our kids whether we wanted to
or not honestly i guess out of cody's 18
children christine is the mother of six
she entered the brown family's plural
marriage in 1994 as cody's third wife i
like my own space i like my own autonomy
christine's desire for independence has
caused major conflict between cody and
the other wives and has been a central
conflict on recent seasons of sister
wives we
don't have to do anything together it's
something e.t spoke to the 49 year old
about earlier this year
i really like living separate i like my
own space i like my own autonomy i feel
like i like me better now as and i just
feel like i've been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to i
really have more of an independence and
i really i just
think the autonomy is really really nice
and i feel like as a person that i do
better with a little bit more distance
so yeah it does get challenging for cody
i'm sure and even i mean it does get
challenging so it really depends on i'm
sure like
so many dads out there it's just the
quality of time that you spend and
really that's when the memories are made
the best is when it's the quality time
so you don't always get quantity time
it's true and especially with this
co-video that we had
there's a lot of times where it's just
me and the girls at home but i mean
that's okay too being able to spend some
time with them has been nice too why
would i want to live
on the same property
with the dysfunctional marriage
where right over there he's got a full
functioning marriage
fans will see more of this play out on
the new season of sister wives
premiering november 19th on tlc
[Music]